in the previous video we found a
solution of a quadratic equation using
factorization we factor the polynomial
on the left and equated the linear
factors to zero there's another
beautiful way in which we can find a
solution of a quadratic equation and
that method is called a method of
completing the square
ignore the name for the moment take this
quadratic equation for instance can you
find a solution of this quadratic
equation yes we transpose this to the
other side to get x squared equal to 4
and this clearly tells us that X can
take two values 2 or negative 2 so we
don't really need to factorize the
polynomial on the left and then equate
the factors to 0 finding the roots was
really easy now let me give you another
quadratic equation you would probably
use the method of factorization to solve
this equation you would get the roots of
this equation as negative 8 or 2 now let
me move this working to the left and
write an equation on the right here it
is how would we solve this we can solve
it just like we solve the x squared
minus 4 equals 0 equation we transpose
this to the right to get this and this
tells us that X plus 3 will either be 5
or negative 5
we get the value of x as 2 or negative 8
and now let me tell you something fun
both these equations are the same this
one is just a modified version of this
one and that's why we got the same
solution in both the cases now I have a
question for you which one was easier to
solve this one or this one
of course it's this one we just have to
transpose the constant to the right and
our job was done so what is completing
the square method all about hips easy we
will be given this kind of an equation
and we will have to write it like this
one and then solve it
as simple as that but the important
question is how do we write this kind of
an equation like this one we see that in
the next video
[Music]